Courtney lovely to meet you so tell is
about hug machine became became courtly
mean how did you get into drag in the
first place I went to a theater school
and I I would dress up as a mouse in
Cinderella or politically correct
anymore but a dwarf in Snow White and
different you know different people who
weren't me
so to put on clothes of a different
gender was just kind of seemed quite
normal by the time I got around to it
and and when I was 18 is I think what
was when I went Courtney was born when
drag sort of really began and I went to
you know the circuit party in Melbourne
uneasy with some friends and got all
gussied up and realized that it was
super great fun and as a performer I was
always looking for like you know when
you're a performer your singer dancer
actor you kind of have to wait quite
often for someone else to give you a go
but the cool thing about drag is you
just turn up to your local you know drag
pageant or whatever and and get on stage
and and there was always there's always
been work opportunities for me which is
wonderful whether it was you know
hosting a Christmas special on channel
for our hosting karaoke on Monday night
at a gay bar in West Hollywood so it's
just been a place where I could always
express my sort of performance side
really easily so it is then it's
Courtney a character or I mean we're I'm
just I'm trying to work out where Shane
ends Kourtney begins or already all one
in the same like two ends of the same
stick right and every person is
different like someone like Dame Edna
for example Barry Humphries is one
person they met her as a character never
never the twain shall meet
whereas for me drag is just a different
aesthetic but still very much the same
person so I could be sitting here you
know in boys clothes and you would get
the same answers and the same I'd
probably be like sitting spike that's
girly sure and I'd be a bit more
comfortable so do you think drag is is
capable of being as subversive as it
once was
yeah and I think the fact that probably
a lot of people what
right now won't even think about this
being subversive because I present like
a sis woman and I think sometimes the
brain especially men men are very visual
creatures and so when they see something
that looks like a duck and talks like a
duck as well yeah there's a duck on
television and then when you sort of
look into it and you like hang on wait
there's a man dressed as a woman talking
about it got it and now that it's
happening in the mainstream I think it's
even more subversive but it's differ
culture in different ways I think and
different people's drag does that like
if you look around you have drag queens
in vogue Italy and vogue America and and
and you have drag queens on runways you
have drag queens with makeup brands with
pop music that as you know charting in
the in the Billboard charts you have all
sorts of you know Bianca Del Rio is a
drag queen who her show is on sale at
Wembley Arena
like that's 14,000 seats like that's
that's as mainstream as it gets but then
to have this performer who you know a
few years ago was you know hosting bingo
at a gay bar in New York City to now be
so mainstream Lee accepted and and every
everybody's style of drag is different
which is what makes it wonderful and I
think that whilst every entertainer is
different I think drag you can visually
see the difference between each person
because we're not confined to what
regular humans look like I aim to
confuse and I think of it you're doing
well well because for me there's this
fascinating concept of like what is
gender and what is attraction and I
haven't gotten to the bottom of it yet
but I I do know that I've dated and and
had sexual relations with straight
identifying men who are kind of like oh
yeah Wow wait it's not a Sheila hang on
oh well and and it's quite fascinating
because we do have these quite rigid and
binary ideas of gender and sexuality and
it's funny because I think my drag does
intersect with gender and sexuality for
me personally I I like
the term gender-fluid really helped me
come to terms with my masculinity and
femininity growing up in Australia you
know in a very masculine sort of culture
I never felt like who I was was good
enough and then started wearing women's
clothes and there was a whole other
layer of shame and so this idea that
gender doesn't have to conform to man or
woman was really liberating for me and
that my gender could be fluid which is
more than just you know the hair and the
makeup it's more an essence of how I
feel inside and then the sexuality where
you know especially straight men they're
usually the ones who are most confused
and aroused all at the same time and and
I think it just it sort of insert
something into someone's perception as
to go like hang on she looks like a
woman but she has a penis and I think
she's attractive what does that mean
what does that make what does that mean
well I think that I think what it means
is that our concept of sexuality is
broken and to say that there's gay and
straight is it's kind of reductive and I
think now we're sort of starting to
understand that sexuality and gender
exist on a spectrum but I just think
that it's been so rigid for so long that
if a straight guy a straight identifying
guy has sex with someone who looks like
a woman that has a penis it's it's like
confusing and they feel that it sort of
ripped something away from their
identity like if you if you want to
identify a straight you still can but
also on paper
I guess that is on the sexuality
spectrum you know Kinsey just talked
about this scale of sexuality and that
might put you on a 1 or a 2 on the scale
as opposed to being a zero but I think
the funny thing is is that people are
scared too especially straight men are
scared to sort of have something removed
from their identity as opposed to seeing
it is like adding to their identity so
just take explain in a bit more detail I
mean you've described yourself as
pansexual you know some who are a bit
more critical might just say what does
doesn't that just mean bisexual I mean
it kind of does
bisexual is the you know better known
term it's been around for longer people
have fought and died for that word and
it sort of was back in the day when it
sort of came about when our
understanding of gender was where it was
it was like oh by men woman and then as
these have evolved and as our
understandings evolved the term
pansexual came about to sort of mean all
genders but then bisexual sort of has
rebranded in a way if you will to sort
of be attracted to genders the same as
my own and definite genders different to
my own and sort of pansexual comes under
the umbrella of bisexual but my my
identification of pansexuality is just
to say that I find someone attractive
irrespective of their gender I have been
with women I've been with trans people
I've been with men and I'm not going to
if I meet someone and I think they're
attractive and I have a spark then I'm
gonna give it a crack in terms of the
gender fluidity that you describe it's
one of the being one of the buzz phrases
of the past couple of years a lot of
people are becoming aware of the the
concept that we are all on it on a
spectrum of some sort between hyper
masculine and hyper-feminine do you see
anything as as as your recovery is a
very very Pro Pro this idea do you see
anything negative in us moving away from
the old stereotypes of masculinity and
femininity I think the only thing that
it could be negative is that people are
so hell-bent on those concepts and like
really we kind of just made up this idea
that women wear pink and boys wear blue
and like there is obviously biological
things about us that are different but
the actual concept of gender and gender
roles in society is just something that
we all agreed upon it's kind of like
this consensual reality where were like
okay yet men will do that women will do
that right got it good nobody needs to
think about it and I think it's it gets
confusing and it does threaten some
people's identities but I think
ultimately what you have to remember is
if someone else is having a different
experience from you that's okay and they
can have that experience and it doesn't
affect or take away from your own
and I think I just think it's really
healthy for men and for women you know
women you know grow up with these
unrealistic beauty standards in
magazines and gender roles men as well I
think men are even more castrated there
I say by their own rigid box of
masculinity like growing up with this
idea that you have to be a man and
creates a lot of shame and a lot of
difficulty in a lot of men's minds
because they they aren't that and I feel
like they have to like not have emotions
and and be a man and that's just not I
don't think that's actually true for 49
percent of the population but they think
things are clearly changing I mean you
know I became a father 3 years ago and
actually I think being a kind of a kinda
generous a kind of an emotion driven
that Paden it is incredible is an
incredibly masculine thing so things
like things are definitely shifting or
and there's this idea of so there's an
idea of man and woman there's an idea of
male and female and there's an idea of
masculine and feminine and we kind of
often think that masculine man and male
are all the same thing and that feminine
female and woman are all the same thing
but really they're they're three six
different things and I think that the I
think that a lot of it is based in
misogyny where we think feminine is weak
it's less than and so like men are
fearful of this idea of being feminine
or embracing emotions or feminine
qualities but feminine doesn't have to
mean woman or female it's just kind of
these words that represent sort of
qualities and I think that can be
confusing as well so where they does
does does drag intersect with with not
just a femininity but but with feminism
itself yeah well I think that drag kind
of holds up a mirror to identity in many
ways and says if like how performative
is my gender presentation right now if I
woke up as a different gender and I
spent I spent probably less time than
Kim Kardashian spends
you know getting ready to go to a on a
TV show so this idea of gender is kind
of a bit a bit peculiar and I think that
to to sort of advertise how performative
my feminine gender is right now sort of
holds up a mirror to you know this these
rigid ideas of what women should look
like and I think when it comes to
feminism I'm a feminist
I support equality of the sexes I
understand it in our society where we're
certainly not there and that there are
there are many things that you know men
have historically been responsible for
and I think that being aware of those
things and unpacking those things is
really important and I hope to be you
know an ally to to women and be seen as
somebody who yeah who supports the
upliftment of of women in our society I
mean want is focus on you you've
described yourself in the past is
polyamorous as well now again for a lot
of people that will be a concept at the
very least that raises eyebrows if that
if indeed they've ever heard of it yeah
just explain a little bit more um I just
I don't believe that I think it's funny
because this idea of monogamy right used
to mean married to one person for your
entire life not just one person at a
time it just meant one person but in
today's society monogamy just means one
person at a time I have been in
relationships before where I was in love
with my partner but I also understood
that I could have like like it's funny
when people go into relationships and
there's this concept that like everybody
suddenly in the world becomes
unattractive but I think we acknowledge
that that isn't the case and if I love
someone and I find someone else
attractive it's not like pie it's not
like I've got a piece of pie and giving
some to somebody else means that the
person I love has got less pie I think
that you know I can love somebody and
that is its own thing and then I can
also love or be attracted to somebody
else so is there an ideal any longer
then not for me the ideal is for the
individual I think as opposed to a
construct that society decided is
appropriate so I might fall in love with
one person and be with them for the rest
of my life I might fall in love with
nobody and be spinster Courtney or I
mean you're not ruling out that I'm an
orchid miss relationship they would last
their denial it's more to do with what
happens with my attraction and it's not
a flippant thing sort of like you know
I'm aware that the grass is greener and
I'm aware that I suppose like in my 20
sexual attraction was much more of a you
know a visceral sort of hormonal thing
whereas now in my 30s I kind of am
probably more rational and less driven
by body parts than I was back then so
it's not that I'm necessarily like
seeking to have her aim of multiple
partners it's more that I understand
that my love for somebody isn't defined
by its exclusivity to them just as like
you have parents and siblings and you
love your obviously in a different way
to your partner but you love your
parents in individual ways and you don't
love one parent more and makes you love
the other parent less I think that sort
of concept of love is something that's
universal with your partners with your
family with your friends people that you
love and then obviously with a partner
there is a sexual element that you don't
have those other people and I just think
that it's more about breaking down the
labels and saying this is this whatever
I feel is correct rather than being told
how to feel do you think though that
would that we can adult talk at we that
the world can can never get that I mean
the one hunt I mean I remember my mom
and dad sing to me when I was very young
like you know gay straight boy it's just
a question of who you fancy which for
you know for the back then was not
necessarily that the most whites were
widely spread widely held view
fast-forward to today and I think you
know pretty much everyone that within my
social circles would would agree with
that but then you look to other parts of
the world where perhaps religion is more
dominant yeah and you know LGBTQ are
being abused on it on a daily basis yeah
I mean there's 36
countries in the British Commonwealth
where it's still criminal to be queer in
some way and that's like just inside our
own you know British Commonwealth and
it's kind of fascinating to think that
because you know that the charter of our
values of the Commonwealth are about you
know equality and and that to me if some
people can still be put to death in some
British Commonwealth countries for you
know committing act of sodomy it's it's
that's pretty that's pretty crazy like
them that's a real thing and I think
that we in the West a very privileged
now you know in the u.s. in Australia
New Zealand Canada the UK and you know
around around Europe that it's where
we're so free to be who we want and I
think sometimes we forget that there are
people who are being put to death or who
are being beaten to death and you know
people are dying and it like it's a very
real thing that's happening in in right
now in history and also we see you know
a lot of fear based politics sort of
trying to take away those privileges
that have been earned in recent times
and I think that it's important to not
take those privileges for granted and
also be aware that there are other
people who don't have those not just
with sexuality or with gender but also
you know reaching across the threshold
to people who might be different to us
and saying I support you know people of
color or I support women's rights or I
support you know disabled people's
rights and and seeing that we can lift
other people up and amplify their voices
in the progress as well